[Music]
[Applause]
ted offensive miley massacre
assassinations of martin luther king jr
and robert kennedy democratic convention
in chicago prague spring and its
backlash mark kurlansky examines the
momentous events of 1968 in his latest
work this week's history on book tv
feature is an hour
thank you all very much
this is not a primary
and everything is non-binding
in
in a writer's life
there are books
that just
come out very suddenly
and there are other books that come out
through a lot of reflection and a very
slow process
uh
this book is the second kind
um
i first started discussing it with my
editor
over 10 years ago
i think i first started trying to make
sense out of 1968
in 1969
certainly i spent a lot of the 70s
thinking about it what was that what
happened
what did it mean
what did it lead to
where has it gone
i spent the whole 1970s wondering what
was going to happen next
and there was this feeling that nothing
was happening next
and then in the 1980s i remember
thinking well no this can't be it
1968
was a unique year in history
a year
in which there were
social explosions
mainly not but not entirely from student
movements
in most countries in the world
and
the interesting thing about this
is that these countries did not really
have a lot in common and certainly
didn't have these explosions were not
over the same issues
if you think about
communist poland in czechoslovakia
and
france under de gaulle
and germany and italy and spain which
was still under franco
and
the united states
and mexico
and japan
totally different issues
and yet
people doing almost the same things
acting in the same way
at exactly the same time
and not
having much contact with each other and
they didn't know each other
the people who led these movements first
of all there weren't many leaders in a
characteristic that all these movements
had in common is that the few people
that you might be able to identify as
leaders
denied that they were leaders
because they were all
anti-authoritarian and therefore
anti-anti-leadership movement so they
were anti-leader leaders
and
in 1968 it was a very big deal to make
an international phone call
people just were not
in contact with people from other
countries very much
and although
certain frustrated
government leaders such as de gaulle and
france and
diazo dots in mexico
looked at events and not without logic
concluded that there was some sort of a
world conspiracy that was just you know
had a checklist and was going from
country to country
it was understandable that somebody
could think that because you know
poland explodes and just as it dies down
germany explodes and just as it dies
down italy goes and then france and then
uh some university in the u.s and
so the whole year went
but not through any kind of organization
at all
um
so i i tried to understand
what the factors were that were that
were causing this to happen
and
of course the first uh factor that was
so much talked about at the time
was the uh
generation gap uh
in the words of grace and kirk at
columbia the fact that
um
people of my age people i was born in
1948 i turned 20 in 1968.
people born
after world war ii
just did not see things the way people
born
before world war ii did
i don't think there has ever been a time
in human history where there has been
two generations who saw things so
completely differently
there is
nothing like that kind of distance today
i say hopefully because i'm a parent
um
the
recently i i i heard one of uh the
lyndon johnson's tapes in which he made
this statement the only choice i had was
between
appeasement and war
i mean that
that is a voice from the 1930s
that made no sense to me in the 1960s
that made no sense in a world with
nuclear weapons
nuclear weapons were one of the things
that made people of my generation see
things very differently
um
i remember the entire time i was growing
up
being obsessed by this idea that there
were these weapons that were going to
destroy the world
uh i vividly remember the cuban missile
crisis
not
at all the way it's often
talked about today about
you know
john kennedy
masterfully getting
the soviets to back down
and so we were protected what i remember
is these crazy people
john kennedy nikita khrushchev they're
playing poker
trying to decide whether or not they
should destroy life on the planet as we
know it
i remember being
really really scared and also really
angry
i remember
hiding under desks and being taught how
to you know cover up in the event of
nuclear attack i remember crouching down
in hallways like this and thinking
you think this is going to work
and people in hungary and czechoslovakia
and poland were doing the exact same
thing and feeling the exact same way
about it
um
the holocaust
had a huge
impact on my generation not just among
jewish people but among all kinds of
people all over the world
because
what nazi germany showed
was the price of a lack of political
activism
what happens if when things start going
wrong
nobody says anything
that was this
this
lesson
that
was
overwhelming
to the post world war ii people
that
you know
things go wrong you don't say anything
well they didn't say anything in germany
and look what happened
um
it was very striking to me
when i was working on this book
and going to other countries and and
meeting with student leaders and
students people who were
active in their countries
whose experiences really were nothing
like mine somebody like adam mishnik who
spent many years of his youth in in
prison in communist poland
um because he protested or you know
people in mexico who
saw all of their friends
killed
and yet
you know i went and talked to these
people and they were all my age
and
we had so much in common we saw
so many things in the in the same way
it was just tremendously striking even
now 35 years later
one of the
other factors
was the civil rights movement
which had been going on for
more than 10 years by 1968
and had gotten pretty savvy
about how to get on television
and
was seen all over the world
and
these people who went down to
mississippi
were tremendous heroes
to a lot of us
and
everybody was intrigued by the things
they did and the things that they
invented and the creativity of
concepts like
sit-ins
and
people felt you know that
this is what you do i mean
people wanted to be like civil rights
workers
so that
when
the polish government closed down a play
in warsaw
and the
students the warsaw students wanted to
do something to protest
they said
let's have a sit-in and then there was
this whole discussion of yeah okay what
do we do now do we i guess we're
supposed to sit down or you know they
weren't really sure what it was but they
knew it was
it was something that had been done in
the civil rights movement and it was one
of the ways
in which uh
you protested protest was in the air
um he protested everything
most of the
important student movements of 68
started on relatively small issues
the first
the first demonstration in
prague
was over badly lit dormitories
the french student movement began over
co-educational dormitories
um
in mexico it began over a
fight between rival high schools
but what invariably happened was that
these demonstrations
would be put down
violently
and then the official repression became
the issue
and they would grow from there
mark rudd the sds leader at columbia in
68 said the issue is not the issue
actually
i i saw mark recently and he said that
he really liked the book but
his one problem was you know when you
said the issue is not the issue you had
it backwards
68 humor
another thing that made
all of these things grow all over the
world was the vietnam war
1968 was the year the worst year of the
vietnam war
and
every week the u.s military was killing
in vietnam
more people
than
died in the september 11th attack
and this was an age
of this was still the age of
decolonization
when
um new countries were emerging breaking
away from colonial
powers and uh
um
to
all of the world
except the johnson administration
that's what vietnam was also as a
country trying to get its independence
and
to the johnson administration
it was a a a step in the in a communist
world plot to take over
almost nobody else in the world
saw it that way
um
and
in many countries including france
germany
mexico
demonstrations
were fairly small
until they became demonstrations about
the american war in vietnam you could
always you could always everywhere get
huge numbers to demonstrate against the
american war in vietnam and so it was
this kind of
unifying
force this is true in the united states
also in 1968 was a very divisive moment
in the civil rights movement
when
snick student nonviolent coordinating
committee uh
was giving up on non-violence
and there was a uh
a split between people like stokely
carmichael and people like martin luther
king
stokely carmichael was a man who
you know had spent 10 years in
non-violent activism getting his life
threatened getting beaten up getting
thrown in jail
and had just had it
um
1968 was the year of uh
the emergence of black power
and there was this tremendous
disagreement about the future of the
civil rights movement between the
non-violent wing and the black power
wing
although
they respected each other much more than
is now said
martin luther king
only spoke well of stokely carmichael
and stokely carmelical always spoke well
with martin luther king but it was very
difficult
to do actions together because there was
this complete disagreement on tactics
but the one thing that they all agreed
on was opposition to the war in vietnam
and so the the
globally around the world
the vietnam
war served as
almost a vehicle of protest
the the other thing
that
was really unique and remarkable about
the year 1968 is that it happened to be
at a very
uh special
time
in the history of the evolution of
television
um
in fact
the evolution of society in general 1968
in 1968 people had this sense
that they were on the edge of a new
world that everything was going to be
different
and it was different but it wasn't
different in the way very few people
imagine the only person i know of
who in 1968 understood exactly the way
the world was changing was marshall
mcluhan and you go back and you read
marshall mcluhan and it's just
absolutely amazing he he saw it all
um how politics were going to change and
how
uh communications and the way people
related that we were on the they were we
were on the edge of the dawn of a
of an age of
television and technology
most of us didn't understand that but we
lived it
a couple of important things that
happened in television one
was
satellite transmissions satellites
making it possible to have live
transmissions
the first live satellite transmission
was in 1958 but for a very long time
you could only do a satellite
transmission from a certain place at a
certain time to a certain place at a
certain time depending on
where in relationship to the earth the
satellite was
so that
daniel shore told me this story of how
this is when he worked for cbs and cbs
realized
that
in this certain week
the satellite would be in a position
so that if he were at the berlin wall
at midnight
he could broadcast live to the cronkite
show in new york
the only problem was that there was
absolutely nothing going on at the
berlin wall at midnight
so he stood in front of the berlin wall
and um
you know walter here i am in berlin
and
uh
as you can see it's very dark and
you hear those dogs barking they
they may be barking at people trying to
jump the wall
or or maybe not
had absolutely nothing to say but it was
it was very exciting because it was live
you know live from berlin
they by 1968 they had figured out uh
geostationary satellites that
stay in the same position relative to
the earth so that you could um
at any time of day from any place you
could broadcast live to any other place
the
other big thing was the change from film
to video
video is first of all much cheaper than
film and you can reshoot it
so
cameras now
can just keep running but you couldn't
afford to do that with film if
if this were film
i would have to say something dramatic
to get him to turn on the camera
but since it's
since his video he can just roll it
it was a huge change in the way news was
covered
but also
film has to be processed and video
doesn't you just shoot it and then
broadcast it
there were
um a number
of at least four
television broadcasts in 1968
that are among
the pivotal moments in the history of
television
the first of which was the ted offensive
um
ted was the vietnamese new year
and the very curious thing
that
vietnam had a very long history of
warfare
centuries of warfare
and during those centuries of warfare
they very frequently did surprise
attacks
during tet
and yet somehow they did it again and
everybody was once again surprised
um
battles in vietnam
uh correspondents would have to get some
ride and some military vehicle up north
somewhere where the battle was taking
place and cover it and then get back to
saigon and ship the film
but the ted offensive took place in
saigon
and very dramatically
at the u.s embassy in saigon u.s embassy
in saigon was in the neighborhood where
all of the journalists not only lived
but filed their stories from
so from from the
standpoint of
transmitting stories
you know the vietcong could not have
picked a better location to attack
and this stuff was just very quickly
turned around and with the
the time difference between vietnam and
the united states
um
every day
that day's battle
was on television at night
which may not strike you as any big deal
but it had never been done before
and
in 1968 this was
you know a shocking and an extraordinary
thing
to
see warfare for the first time on film
it had all kinds of ramifications
there was a uh
a film in 1968 called the green berets
that
john wayne
directed and starred in
and
almost every critic in the country
uh regarded this as one of the worst
movies ever made
and i mean if you've ever seen it
there's there's lots of reasons why you
might think that
but one of the things that almost every
critic singled out
was that
it didn't look anything like the war in
vietnam
i mean there were no black soldiers for
one thing
the landscape didn't look like vietnam
nothing looked like vietnam so you have
this situation where you know here is
the war movie
and here is the war
and they don't look the same
uh
it
became a huge shift in how war was was
uh portrayed by by hollywood it happened
to coincide
with a um a change in in codes with the
with the rating system we have now which
allowed more violence
uh if you rated it accordingly
because there was no way
that you could
have war movies without this violence
when everybody was watching it on
television
and of course the other important thing
was that the war that everybody was
watching on television was not going the
way
lyndon johnson and the military and
everybody was telling
us it was going
um
and it was uh
um the beginning
maybe not the beginning i mean some
correspondence had long before that but
uh
it became very clear to correspondence
that you know the way to cover war
uh was not the way it was done in world
war ii
the way to cover war was
not to rely
on the military command
and the u.s government for information
but to see what was going on in the
field
and to get that information out
i wish that journalists today would
study the coverage of the vietnam war
because
we were able to get a pretty good idea
of what was happening in vietnam and you
know we don't have a clue of what's
happening in iraq in afghanistan
another
really pivotal television broadcast
was the um the riots outside the
democratic convention in chicago in
august
and i remember watching them on tv and
thinking how remarkable this was not
that they were happening because every
demonstration i'd been in had ended up
in violence and
uh
it to people who
demonstrated against the war it was a
you know an accepted thing that this is
how it ended up
but that it was on television
and it was still going on
while it was on television
that you know
people were sitting there in their
living room including people who didn't
go to anti-war demonstrations
and they're they're watching this
violence while it's happening
it just had a huge impact
and at almost the same time
um
the soviet invasion of czechoslovakia
czechoslovakia was was one of the most
important things that happened in 1968
in the very beginning of the year in
january alexander dubeck came to power a
man that people didn't know very much
about who had been a lifelong
communist
and
he
um was
he was very silent actually at first
when he came to power and nobody knew
what was going to go on and he began he
started becoming responsive to student
movements and things that were going on
in czechoslovakia and creating this
society that was that was actually much
more
uh
like what marx had written about a
communist society that was that was open
and had a free press and had freedom of
expression
and there was tremendous excitement
um in a world
that was not very happy with the way the
west was going and was not very happy
with the way the communist bloc was
going
um tremendous excitement about this
other alternative that communism could
become this this other very positive
thing
and then it was just absolutely crushed
by brezhnev
and
it was really the beginning of the end
of the soviet union
and gorbachev years later said that
because
this was a movement of communists there
was a poll in 1968 over 90 percent the
people in czechoslovakia wanted the
country to remain communist
uh it wasn't about overthrowing
communism at all and they regarded
themselves as good allies of the soviet
union and
and you know one of the central beliefs
of communism is that you keep perfecting
society you keep working towards change
to make a better society
and
suddenly it was realized
that
the soviet union would accept absolutely
no change it took away the best reason
for being a communist
the soviets
debated a long time about making this
move
and when they finally decided to do it
they had a plan in which they were going
to tell the world that the dubcheck
government had gone too far
and the people of czechoslovakia
uh were trying to overthrow it and had
asked for the soviets to come in and
help them
the problem was television
it was all on television
and the and the film was smuggled out of
the country and people all over the
world saw unarmed checks facing uh
soviet and warsaw pact tanks
and that film footage was really
the beginning of the end of the soviet
black
and the other
the other really startling television
event of 68 was apollo 8
um
which went to the moon
john kennedy in the beginning of the
decade had said that by the end of the
decade the u.s would go to the moon
and that was you know that seemed like a
hundred years ago in another age an age
before assassinations and before the
gulf of tonkin and before the vietnam
war
uh
an age of optimism that was lost
but now
it was the end of the decade
and we were going to go to the moon
and
you know they're exploring mars right
now
i think this is incredible but nobody
really seems to care all that much
but
you know people were really
excited about this going to the moon
and they broadcast from the far side of
the moon television
and it this was just this
stunning
uh
end to the horrible year the last week
of the year uh live broadcast from the
moon
um
it was a terrible year
i still
when i think back
i still feel the pain
i
feel pain when i think about martin
luther king murdered
i think if bobby kennedy murdered
it was like the death of hope
fifteen thousand americans
died in vietnam that year alone
and several hundred thousand vietnamese
were killed by them
in what the u.s government said was
building democracy
one million children
starved to death
in biafra
a tribal state that tried to break away
from nigeria and the nigerian government
was unable to defeat the militarily but
was able to put a blockade around so
that food wouldn't go in
and so they all starved
and the u.s government wouldn't break
the blockade to bring in food
because they said that they didn't want
to interfere
in a civil war in another country
it was a terrible year
and yet
i think a lot of people
look back on it with nostalgia
and there are a number of reasons for
that
one of them is that it was a kind of a
wonderfully wacky sardonic time
um
you know they used to take
tour groups to the east village in new
york to look at hippies
and uh
they'd go down eighth street say mark's
and you know photograph and look out the
window and there'd be a tour guide there
and say you know on your right you will
see the hippies and uh
and one day the people in the east
village got tired of this and they they
rented a bus
and they went to queens
and they would go up to people and say
excuse me sir why are you mowing your
lawn
i i mean that was 68 also
and 68 in a way was a wonderfully
literary time
it was a time when poetry and poets
mattered uh alan ginsberg and robert
lowell and yep tachenko
and
robert lowell used to campaign with gene
mccarthy
and uh more people ran up to lowell than
than mccarthy
mccarthy got sick of that in about
halfway through the year and
mid-campaign announced that he was a
poet and came out with three poems of
his own
but poetry was everywhere
uh rock bands were named you know the
doers were named after a passage from
blake
and steppenwolf was from hesse
and uh
it was a great time for theater
uh it was the time of uh
fossil of hovel
in prague and
great german theater murat saad and
rosencrantz and guildenstern and julian
back on a really exciting time
but i think
i think that the most important reason
why
1968 has looked back on with nostalgia
is because
it was a time when people felt
they had a voice
that they could change the world
maybe they could at least try
and if you didn't have
anything else available to you you could
just go out on the street and scream
and maybe a hundred thousand people
would scream with you and maybe
something would happen and you weren't
helpless and in an odd sort of way it
was a great age of optimism
i travel around this country a lot now
and
everywhere i go
i talk to
a remarkably wide range of people
different ages and clearly different
politics
but
a lot of people who
don't like what this country is doing
they don't like where it's going
and
and they feel
helpless they feel that there's nothing
that they can do
um
and for those people i think 68 has a
great lesson there are things that can
be done
you know
when young people are sent out to die
instead of being educated and the planet
is being stripped
and corporations are running roughshod
over our life
there's work to be done and there are
things to be done and there are ways of
doing it i just want to end
with a quote from camus
some of you may remember that in 1968
everybody quoted camus
robert kennedy did tom hayden did danny
cohen bendit did so i want to quote my
favorite cameo
in 1968 i didn't have to wear glasses to
do this
the longing
for rest
and peace
must itself be thrust aside
it coincides with the acceptance of
iniquity
those who weep for the happy periods
they encountered in history
acknowledge what they want
not the alleviation
but the silencing of misery thank you
very much
thank you
thank you i'd love to take questions
from anybody but um please uh
step up to the mic over there
hello
um
i'm just gonna
can you um confirm or
refute this uh i've heard a bunch of
historians
talk about um nixon before
johnson dropped out was
um
secretly contacted he was in
uh communication with hanoi
attempting them to delay
a peace deal so he could sort of keep it
a very much a political issue in the
election is that
is that junk history or is that i don't
i don't know i've never seen any
convincing uh evidence of that it could
be true
uh in hindsight it was completely
unnecessary the paris peace talks
weren't making any progress at all
uh hubert humphrey campaigned whenever
he was asked what he was going to do
about the war in vietnam
he merrily said you know humphrey had
this weirdly merry way of talking and he
would say say oh i i don't have to worry
about that that'll be all over by the
time i'm in the white house
but in fact there was no progress being
made
so i i don't know i mean i've heard
those stories i've never seen any
evidence of that
in trying to explain uh why the events
of 1968 occurred in 1968
uh could you mention maybe the coming of
age of the baby boomers
is having an influence there yeah um
sure it did um
not least of all because it meant that
there were an enormous number of people
going to college
and colleges especially in europe were
becoming very overcrowded
which was leading to a lot of student
dissatisfaction this in fact was a major
issue in most european universities was
the overcrowding
yes sir
so what happened i i remember 68 there
were different values i remember uh
money was bad
uh the army was bad drugs were good
no but seriously people were trying were
looking differently for a
different value system a non-consumerist
value system and there were a lot of
people it seemed like everybody was
on the left then what happened well
um
first of all everybody wasn't on the
left i know yeah that's part of the
problem
um
you know one of the great lessons from
68 which came as such a surprise to all
of us but shouldn't have been
is that if you decide to try to change
the world the people who are controlling
the world are going to be pretty
ruthless about stopping you
and
in the united states
richard nixon
completely reconfigured
politics
and
reconstructed a different republican
party i mean the republican party of
1968 would be unrecognizable as
republicans today destroyed the liberal
wing of the party
and fashioned a
a type of politics
that we still see from the republican
party today that's based on fear
and it was a very smart thing that he
did because there was a lot of fear in
68 a lot of
people just
fearing that things were going to just
spin out of control
and the code word for repression was law
and order
um
and there was this this tremendous
um uh response to these
these appeals of fear because
you know cities were burning and and uh
um a lot of things were happening that
uh
um
people just didn't know where it was all
all going to end a tremendous created a
tremendous insecurity
but
it's not that nothing you know there
were no positive results that it
produced the feminist movement for one
thing
it
produced
many positive things all over the world
that took a very long time
to
to be seen
but it just uh
i'm sorry the revolution didn't happen
it's true
um
how has our understanding of the lessons
and significance
of 1968
changed from the world before 911 to the
post-911 world today
well i mean i i have a view of this that
uh
um i
i don't know
you know how many people
agree with my view of it but
um
i think that the really big thing
that happened post 9 11
was
the way it has been manipulated by the
government
um
and the way it has been used to promote
war to curb civil rights
and i think that in the doing of those
things people have started thinking
again about 68
about stopping war about protecting
civil rights and about the things that
were done in 68 to try to do that
a few years ago i came into a book i
can't remember the title or author by a
french woman about the way that 1968
has been downplayed throughout
throughout the years and turned into a
bunch of dissatisfied youths and the you
know the true challenging revolutionary
character of 68 has been uh whitewashed
and there's been to some extent
you know the end of the cold war has
been turned into a vindication of the
right-wing forces who at the time were
pro-vietnam and there's that zero
acknowledgement
which is strange because the whole point
of you know all of these student
movements all over the world you know i
mean go back read the port euron
statement of the sds you know it's what
everybody wanted to do was stop the cold
war uh-huh uh the the cold war was
you know
it was
the great obstacle for
peace in the world and uh
one of the things that all these
movements which we're trying to stop
um
yeah i mean one of the things that that
bothers me
um
is that it tries there's an effort to
reduce it to rock and roll
you know so that the the
the big thing
that happened in in in 1968 was jimi
hendrix i love jimi hendrix but
you know all these things and and there
were tremendous things that happened in
rock music and pop through music in 68
but these things were a reaction to what
was going on it's not as though you know
the things that were going on were a
reaction to the music
um
they're also from the moment martin
luther king died he has been resurrected
as this false
you know fantasy saint
uh instead of instead of the rebel that
he was he was martin luther king was a
wonderful rebel and a great dissident
voice and and and his you know been been
turned into this
tool of the establishment that he never
was
um people rewrite history all the time
yes sir
my name is brian and i want to thank you
very much for being here i'm very much
looking forward to reading the book
you mentioned hubert humphrey earlier
and
his story has always been part of my
fascination with 1968 when i was in
college i wrote a paper about the
relationship or lack thereof between his
presidential campaign and young people
and i was struck by sort of the tragic
character arc of someone who was such a
bright progressive star the democratic
party in 48 and 20 years later seemed to
have zero credibility whatsoever with
this new generation and i'm curious what
were your memories i mean did you fee i
know you were a year away from i guess
voting age in 68 but did you feel it all
engaged by him or no any any hope
whatsoever was no none i i have no idea
i should say i was a year away and i
couldn't vote and i'm grateful for that
because i have no idea what i would have
done
humphrey and nixon were to me two
totally
unacceptable
uh
candidates
uh and undifferentiated
um
well
the biggest issue was the vietnam war
and they were undifferentiatable on that
issue right they were they weren't
offering anything different
um
humphrey also um
did a lot of strange things in an
attempt to uh
steal nixon votes
uh
try to uh
applaud it daily for the attack on
demonstrators in chicago and try to say
that you know the demonstrators deserve
to be beaten up because they used foul
language
which is weird from a man who had spent
years working side by side with lyndon
johnson one of
history's notorious potty mouths
but yeah i mean
uh
johnson had uh
was humphrey was very much associated
with johnson and
um had no credibility to certainly the
anti-war movement in the student
movement in 68
and and yet almost one came very close
nixon was considered an unelectable
politician
um
and uh
you know
only only a democrat that had as much
negative baggage as hubert humphrey
could have possibly lost to
thank you
um being a former maoist
what you've been saying uh leads me to
remember mao ze tung saying that history
is like a boiling pot for decades it may
everything may be beneath the surface
and nothing appears but then all of a
sudden in one year or in a few years
decades occur and that's what happened
in 1968 basically four or five ten years
occurred in that one year and in that
decade you could say decades occurred in
the 60s in terms of things being uh yeah
and and you know
i think there may be a lot of things
going on now that people don't see
there were millions who demonstrated
against the war in iraq there are a lot
of things going on a lot of it
isn't that easy to see because it's not
on the street it's in the internet
tom hayden said to me that in
the early 1960s when he was a student at
university of michigan and he was the
editor of the michigan daily he went out
to california and he wrote these stories
about student movements and all of these
counter culture things that were going
on and he got back to ann arbor and all
of the his faculty advisors said why are
you making up this stuff none of this is
happening and it took about two years
more before you know everybody saw that
these things were happening
let me make one other comment which is
about
you're talking about a lot of good
things were done and i feel in the 50s
60s and 70s is basically the greatest
democratic movement in american history
you figure in 1950 women had the right
to vote but essentially no other rights
african-americans had no rights latinos
asian-americans lesbians and gays
handicaps we're talking 60 to 80 percent
of the population of america gained huge
rights in those decades and we should be
very proud what we accomplished in those
years yeah but we need to accomplish
more the far right knows far better what
we did than we do
hi i'm bianca and i haven't read your
book yet but uh being a pr professional
i was interested
in your whole theory about you know live
television making such a huge difference
and i was 15
in 1968 so
i was surprised did i get this right i
guess i read it in a review that this
was the first year they had live tv
because i thought it was before there
were the first live broadcast was in 58
it was a statement by eisenhower no but
i mean the regular watching of the war
on tv and yeah yeah most of it was not
live most of it was instant replay
um
uh but yeah it was the it was the first
year
of um
uh
live
and of regularly seeing events that
either were happening or had just
happened because i would think that that
would have
really contributed to the whole anti-war
movement oh it certainly did it it
absolutely did and one of the things
that has really um i've gotten to be
hideously cynical
um you know i remember back then i was
you know would march in anti-war marches
even at that age but i would still
believe in the government
you know or think that we could do
things and the country wasn't horrible
i'm having a tough time today
um and you know because now if it's not
on tv it didn't happen so i'm having a
hard time seeing how the internet's
gonna
make that switch
well you know
television
did a lot of useful things in 1968
because it was new and hadn't learned
how to package itself
and i guess that's thank god right now
well we have to find other ways of doing
that yeah now they know how yeah right
okay well thank you look forward to
reading it thanks
one of the takes on the
on the period in 1968
that i've had and i'd
enjoy hearing your comments on it
to some degree i see that there was what
i would term a transformation of
idealism
that sort of came to a head in 1968
from my perception of course the the
kennedy years were over
the decline through the
through the johnson years
the assassination of martin luther king
who held a certain
element of
idealism
and
even things
even things in my own case i i was in
the foreign service
and working for the u.s agency for
international development in nigeria
during this period
and one of them during the biafra yes
exactly and one of the senses that i had
over there and i had it when i came back
to the states off and on during that
same year
was that the idealism of of africa the
hopes for nigeria
uh the great writers of sryanka
and these people were kind of dashed by
by the tribalism and again
essentially the war so yeah i mean the
emotional uh psychological impact of the
biafran war
because as you say i mean nigeria was
one of the new emerging nations that had
uh that that people had the greatest
hopes for
um
and you know this too was was on tv and
in the media and we all saw these
starving children every day and it
it had a a huge
psychological effect on people all over
the world so in a sense just generally
in 68 my my sense of it was that much of
the idealism of earlier in the decade
had run into great difficulty in seeing
it played out and and progress being
made and there was a certain degree of
of reaction to it that of the
hopelessness of the situation which led
as a matter of fact i made a note uh
when you were talking about the poets
well here's here's one thing you have in
in popular culture
the the musical hair with the first
nudity that i ever saw on the stage
unbelievably 1968 right
before that
the culture that i was more feeling you
know raising in the sun to kill a
mockingbird more serious and and less of
a kind of frustrated lashing out at
things that weren't well i mean there
was a lot of really serious theater at
68. hair was you know
what was hair about it was about the age
of aquarius i think yeah
it was part of this whole
thing of let's try to find out what the
hippies are doing
thank you thank you
my name is joe fisher thank you very
much enjoyed your
reminiscence of
that year uh you raised the issue of
mark rudd that you talked to him
recently and i'm quite curious and as
time has gone by and he reflects on what
he did and where he did it and the
enormous damage that was done to
columbia university
does he have any
any regrets at all about maybe picking
that particular place
for
bringing the kind of conflict that and
decisions that were made
and the enormous damage it was done to
that university um
well
i hate to be put in the position of
speaking for him
but i have talked extensively to him
about these things and and my
impression is is that
uh
he has
a lot of regrets about the
post-68 period the weatherman period um
but not know really about colombia uh
it was felt that colombia was a
university that i don't know that it was
damaged i think it was changed for the
better i
i talked to i know a lot of people who
teach at columbia now
and
by and large they're glad it happened
colombia was was was an absolutely
stuntifying place in 1968
and
was very deeply involved in in the
american vietnam war machine and was not
you know
mark rudd went to colombia thinking that
it was you know the the castle on the
hill where people debated ideas and
intellectualism and found that you know
it was all about money and real estate
and and and developing weapons and uh
um
well i i'm
i'm getting trapped into speaking for
him and i
i've said enough in the voice of mark
roger one last other question uh
obviously many at the time in 1968
vilified lyndon johnson i mean i
remember the chance and so forth i was
coming life active duty at the time when
i was back here in washington
again with the passage of time when they
go back and they reflect on his
presidency they have
some reassessment i mean my own sense
was is that johnson more than any
president had a firm
a commitment in his bones as a
southerner as a politician
to making achieving racial justice which
he did and pushing through the 64 civil
rights act the 1965 voting rights act
which i think were really where the keys
that were handed to the republicans to
pitch to the dark angels of the south
yeah i i i would tend to agree with you
personally though i have no regrets
about trying to stop the killing that he
was unleashing
well thank you for your comments and and
and your book and
it's been especially um interesting
tonight having some somebody else who
was in the middle of all this to hear
what other people
of the same age were were feeling at the
moment but i wanted to make a comment
and then ask a question related to that
in 1968 i was i was i had been a grunt
in the civil rights movement and i was
getting involved in the anti-war
movement
today i'm still sort of a paid organizer
for many national organizations in the
course of the course of my work in the
last 20 or 30 years i've traveled around
the country a lot as you said you've
done and talked to many people and
at the risk of sounding too optimistic
and a hard time um i've i've come to the
conclusion the last 10 years
that busy as it was exciting as it was
in 1967 68 69 even 70 for those of us
who are there
my feeling in talking particularly to
young people on campuses and you know
democratic party activists and even
republican party activists you know in
various parts of the country
um is that
there's a million times more people
working on the issues that we cared
about in 196 in 1968 than there were
then i i think that the thing that i
have felt and i wonder if you've
agreed with this or not is that
in 1968 was real important in so many
ways because the great unifying thing
was being against the war so you felt if
you went to an anti-war
demonstration if you went to any kind of
a meeting the war always came up and
there was this unifying thing where you
could see who your allies were
now that's not so it's sort of true of
the iraq war but it's not as true
but i find when i look at the
environmental movement and the
anti-sweatshop movement boy there's a
million more people especially people in
their 20s and 30s millions more who are
really involved engaged in every way
more than you know more than i i
don't spend a lot of time on college
campuses but i have been on a few of
late
and it's my impression that um
uh
young people college students are being
very underrated but there's a lot of
them who really do care about issues and
are impassioned about these things and
and
prepared to do things about them i think
it's uh
um
i i think they're being very
underestimated yeah and i think given
what some people have said about you
know what's happened and
being under the radar screen i think
these are the the kids who are under the
radar screen now who are doing really
major work on you know the globalization
issues sweatshop issues all these kinds
of things big big time environmental
stuff and that there may be some sort of
a
major positive explosion in the coming
years of these people i i agree with you
i just want to sneak this last guy in
because i'm over my limit and he's the
last guy and i want to hear what he has
to say
well you may not want to actually
oh no no you could we rerun the tape if
i don't like it
just a footnote
um i was a so in a life a time of
realism when you have only two choices
to make the question is
which was what what were we better off
with so i just want to leave that small
note
that despite the
the sense of loss of hope of that time
it was a pretty difficult experience to
go through in terms of trying to get
where we wanted to get
i'll leave it at that too
thank you
thank you very much
folks
is author of cod salt and the basque
history of the world his latest 1968 the
year that rock the world is published by
valentine bucks visit randomhouse.com
bb for more information
next week on history on book tv jeffrey
kimball on the vietnam war files
if you're interested in finding out
about the authors and books featured on
history on book tv
you